okay here we go
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to another episode of your
favorite podcast
welcome back
[Music]
all right everybody welcome back we're
gripping we doing it
once again i'm here wigs is back in town
we're doing our thing back here i'm
ripping with griffin live at river with
griffin studios
facing the riverwood griffin stage but i
just want to thank everybody for being
here
today i'm going to talk about we got
real world advice from a grown ass man
i'm gonna go into the brittany situation
i'm gonna go into
our my parents meeting rachel's parents
but again welcome to riffing with
griffin
all right that was the intro but before
i get to the intro ladies and gentlemen
i want to have a big shout out to our
sponsor right now
helix sleep helix sleep
big shout out take their two minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to the
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
i love helix sleep my back is great
because of it helix is offering up to
200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixfleet.com griffin that's
helixsleep.com
griffin all right
and we're here um we're back again
just to get all caught up you know like
i say wiggs is back you know uh
last week he was uh you know he's with
his his mom and i'm sure your dad is
like
still upset about getting called out for
his uh
he thought he thought it was funny all
right good
[Laughter]
yeah no they were hyped my whole my
whole family watched the episode
ah that's good they were all screaming
uh i love it you know
everybody was looking at your dad like
yeah exactly my grandma was like
clock so we have to ask for wigs is back
so we'll get into some more stuff with
him a little bit later but
um and then uh just you know thanks for
being here once again guys
like i said we got a big episode because
i'm doing a real world advice from a
grown-ass man
and then i got uh i want to talk about
the britney situation uh and i'm gonna
talk about just some stuff that's
generally going on with me today was
messed up because somebody broke into
rachel's car it is i hate
when somebody breaks into your car it is
such a violation
like the things that you lose unless
it's something precious to you something
that irreplaceable like most things can
be replaced you know
you know somebody steals your watch or
something some stupid thing you left in
the car
and you you think about it it sucks but
after a while you just kind of go you
got to go you know what i can replace
that
but the thing that you that sits with
you is that you feel
violated you feel like somebody just
some
somebody stole something from you you
know no pun intended but that's just how
you feel
and it just sucks and then she was
really upset because she's lost a couple
of really great sunglasses that she just
got these really like
expensive sunglasses you know you have
your sunglasses in the car and these
these
suckers and you know the problem is i
moved her car and didn't even notice
but i just thought because nature was
kind of messy so there's like [ __ ]
everywhere in her car
you know so i got in the car and there
was [ __ ] like on the in the pat and the
driver's side too on the ground i was
like damn rachel why you so messy
didn't even look to see that like the
glove compartment and all this stuff and
then her trunk was open
and i thought that i hit the button on
the thing and opened the trunk by
accident so i was like why is her trunk
i didn't i didn't even acknowledge it
until
i you know i came back and she's leaving
and she gets in her car she's like yo
somebody
stole stuff from my car so i don't know
if we left the door open or whatever
happened
but it doesn't even matter like people i
hate when people ask you that you go man
somebody stole [ __ ] from my car and they
go would you was your
door unlocked as if that's that means
if your door's unlocked well carb
launched that means you know if i check
a door
it's unlocked it means i can steal
everything and i know that's the kind of
feeling that you have but it still
sucks i i just i i i feel
violated by that so it sucks but uh this
past weekend i did something i haven't
done this yet
is that rachel's parents met my parents
for the first time
rachel and i went like wedding venue
you know things her mom and her are
really excited about that so her mom was
like looking at all these places and
so we went to go look at this place and
it's sort of near where my parents are
and so
you know i was like well maybe this is a
good time for our parents to meet
because
like you say as you guys know if you
listen to the podcast my mom has
dementia
uh so and it could be dementia is like a
really tough thing man
i've talked about it before but man
i'm really trying to not think about it
every time i see my mom but i can't help
it
because she's not the same person and it
is so tough
it's so tough and then like so i'm
introducing her to people that don't
really know her
so all they know is what they see and
she's like a sweet lady you know and
you know she's making jokes and she's
repeating herself and all this
but i know who my mom is i know this
strong woman who raised me and like
is like you know what i mean and it's
not that person and so it's tough for me
to like you know
see it and i know i have to get over it
i know i got to get past it it's like
people say that people tell you like
it's so easy just to move beyond things
but it's like it's hard
for me personally that i witness it
every single time
you know and i'm trying not to live that
but it really is hard
and so now i have this moment where this
would have been like a great moment in
the past of like
here's this woman i'm gonna marry who i
love and my you know something my mom
always wanted from me and
and then like she can't even really
appreciate it and so i feel like oh man
this is like a lost
moment but my stepfather you know
mike uh salted the earth you know and he
was he's a yapper man he he started he's
a kind of guy he'll tell stories
that you didn't even ask him to tell the
story his ass will start telling the
story
he you know i mean he got facts about
stuff you go i didn't ask you about this
but he's like well you know in 1975 you
know i mean he's that kind of guy
so he was going in and i knew he would
get along with rachel's mom so they were
just going back and forth and i thought
well you know what this is still nice
you know we're still making the best of
this and so we had a nice lunch
it was good to see my mom and then you
know mike took her off
and uh you know that was that so you
know i got i was nervous about that i
don't know if
people out there that you know you're if
you're married or you're you know or
you're really serious with someone
you know you have that thing where
you're like okay you got your your
parents got to meet or
you meet the other person's parents you
know this this that it's a really uh
you know it sometimes it can be a little
uncomfortable i remember the first time
meeting rachel's parents and rachel's
parents like
her her dad's like 6 11. he's a
monster of a man you know so i remember
looking up like oh [ __ ]
let me treat this woman right you know
what i mean and then her brothers are
big you know what i mean so she's got
like a
i'm hoping we have some basketball kids
you know because i'm six three rachel's
six foot so it's like whoo
i want to we hope we make a nba player
you know what i mean
[Laughter]
uh but i hope they have they better have
her looks and like my brains
and my sense of humor my singing voice
you know her sweetness you know to me
because if it's opposite we're going to
try again immediately
it's going to be if we have one kid and
the kid looks like me and not like her
all right
back to the drawing board let's do this
again you know but
we'll still love them the same i'm just
obviously i'm making a joke
so but that was um cool you know and
it's like
one of my buddies um one of my other
comedian friends called me the other day
um i won't say who it is because it's
like this is his business you know but
he called me to say to me like hey
i heard you were in the same situation
because he's called to tell me about his
mom
you know and his mom has dementia and
it's like
oh man you don't understand how it is to
talk to somebody and that's what alanon
is if anybody knows what that is it's
like a support group for people who
have a loved one in their life who's
addicted to drugs or alcohol
and you have this support group for love
you know and you
and there's something about talking to
someone else who gets it
like they understand you know like
you're talking to them
and you can say things like you know you
feel guilty or you feel like all the
things you feel and when you feel
someone else is like i feel those things
too
it makes you feel less alone it makes
you feel like oh man
they understand someone understands me
or i'm like oh i'm not crazy this
feeling that i feel you know
so you know you have those feelings when
you know
loved ones have alzheimer's dimension
that kind of thing you have these
feelings and sometimes you have really
dark feelings sometimes you have like
you know it's like
damn my parents are go i feel like my
parent is gone i want this to end
you know you have these like sort of
dark feelings and it's like sometimes
and i'm just telling you even from going
to my own therapy it's like it's
okay to say certain things out loud it's
okay like whatever you're feeling
feel it you know and if you have someone
you can share it with share it with that
person so you can just
know how that feels and then you just
try to deal you know so
if you're out there dealing with that
and uh i i feel for you i totally get it
and i i did mark marin's podcast i was
on what the [ __ ] uh wtf and uh
i told a story i was talking about and
i've gotten a lot of great emails from
that there's a lot of like actually
really great listeners
i'm so used to like troll ass listeners
from tiger belly and
bad friends in that world i'm so used to
like people hitting me up with this like
negativity that i forget that
there are other podcasts out there and
other people who actually
they actually listen and they go hey man
i appreciate this this instance so
it was nice to have a different type of
audience and it's not all the people
that listen to
that are like that but i'm just saying a
lot of the trolls that i get i know they
come from there and it's just sometimes
it just gets annoying it was nice to
have people hit me up
because i also told a story about like
you know i'm only child single parent i
don't know my dad i've never met my dad
before and it just really doesn't bother
me you know
maybe it should maybe it bothers me deep
down or when i see other people
you know i go oh and that's how that is
but it's just something that i never
uh i never thought about and and you you
have a lot of feelings when you uh
you've been in this situation you know
you you know you think about like
you think about like well why didn't my
dad want to
get in contact with me did my mom keep
him from me you know what is their
personal thing that went on because you
don't know what happened
50 years ago whatever it is you know
when they decided you know they did do
they did what they did
you know you don't know so i don't but i
don't hold it again i never held it
against my mom
because i understand i'm actually like
people do [ __ ] they have personal things
that go on and they make certain choices
that affect people
you know but i don't have any resentment
about it but but there's so some people
hit me up about that too i got a lot of
great emails from people like yo man i
uh
i've experienced the same thing uh you
know so i really appreciated
some of the emails that i got about uh
this this subject one guy sent me a
really long email and i haven't got a
chance to hit him back yet
and then he hit me but you know when you
know when you send somebody a long email
and then like they don't get back to you
then you kind of take it personal so the
dude's in his feelings right now
and he like sent me another email good
talk man you know he was like
but i get it because he revealed a lot
of like important things but
so i'm publicly reaching out to that guy
i'm letting you know dude i heard you
and i do appreciate it i just
i didn't know what to say back but i
will write this guy back
you know what i mean so anyways you know
shout out to all those new
if i have any new podcast listeners from
that that came from wtf thank you and a
shout out to mark maron for having me on
the podcast
that was really that was fun you know it
was a fun conversation in in it
and it's a different world just audio i
realize it's a different world because
when i listened to the edited version i
was like oh yeah they took out
pieces of the conversation that where it
didn't work but when you do it like this
you got to keep everything in because
the edits look weird when you take them
out
of youtube because you don't use video
and audio but i don't know
wigs is uh doing the the the editing
sometimes so he kind of does he does
good edits
so i realize it's okay if you ever
edited you haven't had it but sometimes
when you have an edit on youtube a video
people go hey man what'd you cut out
would you you know you just naturally
feel like hey that was an edit and i
wonder why they did that
sometimes it's a multitude of reasons
but it's to keep the conversation
flowing so that's
what uh that's about so it's not always
what you think guys
um yeah so there so that was that i had
that really great like i said i had a
great lunch with
my parents and rachel's parents so that
was cool rachel's sunglasses got stolen
so
you know they were really nice
sunglasses i wish i knew the brand so we
could reach out to them but
you know now she wants these tiffany's
sunglasses and like anytime something
bad happens
rachel hits me with that like oh i don't
know what i'm like sunglasses
what am i gonna do you know that's just
like okay honey i'll take care of it you
know what i mean
she knows how to play it up man she does
she
but i get it it's like when you it's
like that's it don't matter how
expensive something is it's yours and
when somebody takes that
you feel that so [ __ ] you
thieves i don't care if you needed it or
not you know you're a piece of [ __ ]
all right you never had anything stolen
you ever had your car broken into wigs
um
yeah but they never took anything we had
a problem where
people would come up from this like come
through this park
near our house in seattle and they'd
like walk like
homeless people or whoever would walk up
from the park
next to heroin park no car key park
and uh it's a pretty chill little park
but at night it gets
just yeah sassy sexy yeah something
about a park man
people feel like you know what i wanna i
wanna go do drugs and do violent stuff
at the park like it's it's a weird how
it could be a beautiful place if you
take kids and
you also take your your heroine once the
sun goes up yeah
yeah but yeah people would walk up and
then uh
sometimes we wouldn't leave our car
locked and then they'd just like go
through
everything and leave everything there
dude because we wouldn't leave anything
in the car so you don't know about this
because you're too young but
i used to have they used to have this
thing called two things they had to pull
out radio you know what a pull-out radio
yeah i know about that and then the
the uh what about the steering wheel
oh they had that thing that okay but
forget that i'm just talking about the
radio
i've had my radio stolen from my car so
many times when i was young when i was
your age and younger
so they used to then you had a pull out
so you had to like pull the radio out
but either but so people were carrying a
radio around which was [ __ ] stupid
when you look back on it or you put it
in the trunk or whatever you did with
your radio put it under the seat you
know whatever
then they had a thing called detachable
faces so you had the radio was in there
but you would take the face off and it
was unusable without the face
okay yeah that's what i know about i
don't know about the whole radio i know
yeah
like just the pop out thing no you used
to be able to pull the whole radio yeah
my dad even in his truck still has like
a detachable
yeah you can pop it out so right so he
doesn't do it anymore so one time i had
the detachable face i took it off i come
in
it's gone the uh the base is gone
so some [ __ ] out there are still
with a base
the fake that's just a [ __ ] you trying
to find the face that's just
a [ __ ] you that's just like that you
know you can't use this without this
face and you still took it
god it pissed me off i'll never forget
that so i've had my car broken into a
few times and i remember
moving because my car got broken into
like i'm actually on a tip right now
that i might move
i just moved into here what just
happened makes me feel like i know
that is weird yeah i mean it's like it's
a locked
that's what i'm saying parking garage
don't even get me started so like
somebody got in
and it's it's just really it's really
frustrating
yeah and you hope it's not just like
someone that literally no
no it's not i there's a couple of fences
i could see like in the back there
i was looking on the back like when you
go out my door and you go to the left
there's actually a fence that you can
like
i think it's easy to jump over that
fence you hop the fence and then you can
just go down to the parking lot so it's
like
anyways i'm not even going to harp on it
it just sucks it is what it is yeah
right so what it is whack so but here's
something that's really bugging me
and i it just seems weird maybe it seems
with you but
a few people out there but this britney
spears situation
i i want to talk about this brittany
thing
i'm on this free brittany tip right now
okay
britney spears has been in a
conservative ship
for um
what you doing over there trying to find
some britney's
oh okay i got you that's just for me
right okay i got you so um
uh anyways brittany's been in this
conservative ship now for 13
years you know that baffles my mind we
kind of don't think about it we kind of
like
on the outside looking in we're just
kind of like
oh yeah britney went crazy you know she
you know
she was she shaved her head and she like
you know had no underwear on getting
into a car
she had that umbrella situation like she
had all of this stuff
go on in her life and we sort of know
about it outside
you know just being outside looking in
and then the tabloids played it up and
it was just a whole thing about her
and we're just kind of like whatever
about it then i come to
realize i go wait hold on she hasn't
been in control of her own life
for 13 years
and i start to go hold on man this is
crazy like this is a legal arrangement
that grants go back up
that grants oversight of her personal
life and finances
to her strange father to her father now
i'm about to say there's a lot of things
i want to talk about with this but
here's the first thing i want to say
okay
now if you know me if you're not if you
have been listening to the podcast from
the beginning if you listen to me
regularly
you know i'm a reasonable [ __ ]
you know that i
i i don't take the right or the left i
i'm i i can see both sides i try to use
common sense i'm a very reasonable
rational person when it comes to
the things i say now casual listeners
might come in
and these casual trolls they come in
they're like oh here's
your leftist they think because i'm in
hollywood that i'm like some sort of
elite a leftist type guy i'm not
i i'm telling you i'm not but you that
this is just for the casual fan that
might come in on this point right here
because of what i'm talking about
this might get some extra love because
britney spears is so popular but i want
to say this
this is some male white privilege
[ __ ] guys
hear me hear me out her
father has been in complete control
of her life for 13 years
now if she was in some
drug facility or some mental health
facility
incapacitated you'd be like well maybe
she needs to be in this situation right
but
damn if a [ __ ] can be
on tour so she could be on tour making
money but she can't be in control of her
own life
come on like this is this dude is
like the fact that he is in charge of
her life the way
he is and he and it's been unchecked for
13 years
and she's like if it was bobby spears
if it was some dude do you think the
father would be able to
be like in control of the money and all
this stuff in the same way
it's just you know is would chris
brown's father be able to like i know
it's not an
analogous but like you know he was going
through some stuff too can his father
just swoop in and
and take over his life yeah i mean
justin bieber
justin bieber is another thank you wiggy
justin bieber's another one that like
he's been going through a lot of [ __ ]
man
through his life you know that he was
peeing in buckets and he was
all this kind of stuff that we heard
about you know uh i like i briefly know
justin bieber so
he's a cool kid you know what i mean but
like from the outside looking in you saw
all these things that you might think
well should his parents step in
would they i don't think they would have
been able to step in like that but
britney spears being a woman and then
her white father
you know what i mean it just like and
then that he's been able to keep this
going for 13 years
she could do a vegas reagan's residency
but she can't run her own life
she could go on a world tour but she
can't run her own life
like damn it sounds messed up look i
don't know
the whole situation okay but just from
the
outside looking in it don't feel right
to me
it feels funky man it feels like
this is somewhat sort of like indentured
servant type of situation going on
it feels dirty you know and then i
listened to her
talking in court she don't sound like a
crazy person
she sounds self-indulgent and she's you
know she sounds like a
a pop star man she sounds like a crate
like a
a rich white woman who like is like my
wife isn't i don't
own my own life and i feel her i don't
think it was necessary for her to throw
paris hilton under the bus and
miley cyrus under the bus but at the
same time
she was making a coherent thought she
don't sound like somebody
who's who needs to be in a thing where
her whole life is being controlled
they make her wear a iud they make her
uh you know she got a boyfriend she's 39
years old she's like i love this man i
want to have a baby with him
and she has to get permission from
someone else like if she can even have a
boyfriend
then she can make choices like i don't
understand
this conservative ship i just do not
understand it
you know you gotta listen and you know
you listen to her like she wasn't
rambling on she sounded angry
she sounded like hey [ __ ] my life has
been i haven't been in charge of my life
for 13 years i got kids
like imagine what her kids feel about
her then you read these stories about
how
the dad hit one of the kids the dad's
the dad was using the kids
like if you don't do what i want you to
do you're not gonna see your kids like
this guy sounds like he needs to get his
ass beat that's what it sounds like to
me man
it sounds like somebody that like and
then she's like you know
she man family is [ __ ] up
she says in the uh the thing she's
talking about like you know
he loves having this power over me
because you know
you know and she sounds full of herself
but why not you britney [ __ ] spears
i don't mind her being full of herself
okay i really don't
i don't mind her being full of herself
but this dude man
yeah who's this guy who's this guy
to like have this sort of power and
control
over his daughter like
it doesn't sound like at any point he is
looking out for his daughter's
well being like you don't hear about
oh he he has her in this sort of
treatment she's been doing this there's
no updates like
she you know brittany's doing well now
and blah blah blah you know there's
nothing it doesn't
feel like he's trying to make her better
she's talking about being forced to sign
contracts to do
concerts and she had to be this vegas
residency and
all this is going on you know
like what she just sounds like a cash
cow
like really he has this like pop doll
like his daughter is a pop doll and he's
like okay
go get like a circus monkey go make us
money
like where's all this money i hope i
hope that judge goes you know what miss
spears you have your life back
and then she sues the [ __ ] out of
everybody that has put her in this
situation
man i mean it's absolutely crazy like
listen i don't want to be one of these
like
you know i'm not listen like i said i'm
trying to be rational and reasonable
about how i feel about it
but to me this screams of like
weird-ass male white privilege man you
know
and i'm not one to harp on that kind of
stuff i'm telling you guys i know you
might be
you might be a white guy out there like
here we go and you're going into right
now but
come on man this guy is keeping his
daughter in a conservative ship
for 13 years making her go on tour
making all the things
making her wear an iud you know
controlling when and when she can see
her kids
uh you know controlling all of her money
her entire life
she's never alone she's always got
people watching her and it's like damn
enough's enough man enough is enough
free britney free right
yeah free britney oh yeah and it's just
like
you know she should be allowed
to be a monstrous pop star
egotistical all that she's allowed to
feel that way
to me it's like that has that is not the
reason why
like imagine she sounds more sane now
after going through all this
than when she was having some whatever
breakdown she was having
now she's in court just like you can
hear it in her voice she is
mad like she's mad and i'm mad for her
too
but i don't know all the situation
listen i don't know all the facts i'm
not in
in her life but from the outside looking
in
this [ __ ] don't smell right it don't
smell right
free britney free britney what do you
think big facts
um i think it's crazy yeah i mean the
big facts big
facts they uh they gave her lithium
yeah they gave her lithium prescribed
her lithium which was like not her
regularly
described prescribed uh medication which
is just
wild and she also said that that wasn't
yeah
that's just like not what she should be
taking and that it just made her
life living hell yeah she's saying like
you know she's saying like these drugs
and all this stuff
this is the reason why maybe when i've
come to court in the past i i haven't
been myself
yeah she said i mean she also she's like
i've been lying for
like last time i came to court i was
lying and i just didn't know what to do
and i've just been lying to the world
like saying everything is okay and what
else is she supposed to say
like imagine if you're like how do you
get your life she didn't know she could
she didn't know she could uh
get her own lawyer get her own lawyer
and petition the conservatorship at all
she didn't i mean it's
like yeah it's it's it's it's completely
and utterly outrageous and like i say
i i like look we we can't allow this
just to go
unchecked look you're out there in the
public and you're just thinking to
yourself like
you know what do we care about but you
know what this reminds me of oh man i'm
so glad i remembered this
there was this movie that just came out
and it's like what is it uh it's called
i care a lot oh yeah this movie on
netflix called i care a lot and it was
about
this it was about taking over taking
over
taking old people's money away from them
making them incapacitated and then they
take all their money
that's what her dad britney spears dad
is that
woman from i care a lot yeah that's what
he's been doing to her
literally millions of dollars like what
if she had nothing like could this be
done to anyone
you know what i mean it's like oh man
it's it's
yeah it is really it is really
interesting because it's like you just i
mean
if if this happened if they tried to do
this to justin bieber like
you know it'd be yeah could they even do
it i don't know that's what i'm saying
like it's just it's it's just it screams
to me of like
it smells like some like you know
you know when you hear about like how
it's a male world and all this kind of
stuff it smells of that
you know it's a stink it's thinks of
something rotten guys
and whatever the bad part of society is
this this
feels like that's a part of it
yeah that's what i mean that's britney
spears's father right there from i care
a lot it's just a monster
just an absolute and complete monster
all right guys um i want to talk to you
wait let me get my uh
ipad open here you know i do my my ads
live in full effect um
but you know i want to talk about my
great sponsor
of the show better help
better help better help better help you
know so therapy
therapy is important you know it's like
uh when my friend called me
about his mom with dementia i said to
him self-care is important
because i'm even telling myself that
self-care is important because
of how something like that affects you
you have to make sure you're taking care
of yourself and talking about things in
therapy and having like support is very
important
and better help is here for you you know
you can connect in a safe online
environment it's convenient
you can start communicating with
somebody in 48 hours
all without having to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room but
i recommend therapy it doesn't solve
your problems guys just
but it helps you recognize some
some key points it helps you recognize
like maybe the origin of why you feel
the way you
feel helps you connect the dots with a
professional who understands these
things and that's why it's important
it's a lot of things that affect your
life affect your mood depression stress
anxiety relationships
anger you know britney spears need some
some freaking better help you know what
i mean i was i'mma send britney my code
you know what i mean
she needs to get into that there's so
much stuff self-esteem confidence
there's so many different things
that therapy will help you with and this
is uh better help is great for that it's
it's it's
affordable it's not a self-help it's
actual trained therapy with a licensed
therapist
and in fact so many people have been
using better help that they're
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states so it's actually a really
great service and i
highly recommend it i want you to start
living a happier life today
as a listener you'll get 10 off your
first month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
griffin join over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
that's betterhelp.com griffin
for 10 off your first month better help
so as we have our better hub sponsor i
um
you know i want to go into uh which i
haven't done in a long time which is
real world advice let me get my singing
real world advice from a grown ass man
okay so real world advice from a grown
ass man is back and like i say i ain't a
licensed therapist
i'm just giving you some common sense
advice some grown man advice this is
what i think about your situations but
if you are experiencing stress anxiety
anything like that some real feelings
you're feeling dark feelings
i really i highly suggest you reach out
and get some help
and you can use better help if not just
use whatever help you want no we don't
need to put the thing on
but this is just a real this is real
advice my first advice is get some help
if you need some help but
all right so let's uh go what we got
wigs what's the first what's first up
now that i got him back here he'll read
them now even though you might see you
don't have to see it on the screen but
whatever
so first one is uh my ex
is talking to me and we hooked up behind
her new boyfriend's back
i still love her but it's difficult
because it's long distance
oh this is tough you know this is one of
these things where it's like
when someone's been in your life when
someone uh
you've been intimate with and close with
when they're in your life
sometimes it's hard to like you always
have remnants of that relationship
with you at all you realize you never
really let those things go
but what's good for you and what's right
for you and what's bad for you sometimes
the lines get blurred
you know and this is one of these things
is this is your ex
she's your ex you know and it's a power
trip you were on
why you did that you know it's like an
ownership thing you were trying to pee
on her
you know it's basically what it is she's
with someone else and you're in for your
own benefit you
you you did this thing with her and just
like yeah she's still
mine but ultimately that's not going to
be a good situation you know
first of all it's long distance she's
already with someone else
so it's already like the lines are
already blurred and are you really happy
is it really about like being with her
is it really about like this
relationship moving forward and working
things out
no it ain't about that it's about this
like leftover residual
feelings that you know it's manifested
in this sort of sexual tension but just
because you can
doesn't mean you should let me say that
again just because you can
doesn't mean you should and so
i understand why you did it but i think
that that that's the kind of thing where
you got to let
that go you got to move on from this one
and
let it go
all right that's what i got for that one
good luck dude
what else we got next one is uh
i heard your wtf and i have a similar
father storyline i found him should i
reach out
should you reach out yes i think you
should reach out why not
i mean unless there's some like
circumstance where you feel like you
shouldn't reach out you know what i mean
like
but like if like i don't know were you
adopted
is it was he a deadbeat was he just like
are you doing it for you
are you trying to build a relationship
but if you're gonna regret
not reaching out then you should if you
because you have the information
you you in your thing here you said i
found him so that means you were
searching
if you were searching and you found now
do something with that information
you just have to be prepared for
whatever you find out
it might be something you don't want to
hear it could be that the dude just was
like
he was just like i wasn't prepared to be
a dad and i just i couldn't deal with it
he could have just been weak at the time
and now maybe he's like you're you know
what kind of energy you bring to him
could change the whole situation
it could be that you know you're going
to be like hey i forgive you maybe
you're angry though maybe you want to be
like
[ __ ] you for doing this to me why'd you
not look for me why'd you not be my dad
you know
whatever your energy is you know you you
know what you have that in you
but you already went through the the
painstaking
process of finding him you found him
now don't maybe but also
that could be all that you needed you
could be done you could be like you know
what i just wanted to know
what he looked like i wanted to know but
for me it's like
i don't know my dad could be dead for
all i know because at this point he's
probably 90 years old or something like
that because i think
he was way older than my mom and my
mom's 78 so who even knows i can have
brothers and sisters and
so for me finding my dad would be about
that
it would be about knowing like hey is
there some gene things i should be
worried about like
do you have cancer in your family you
know i'm saying like sometimes you want
that type of information
do i have brothers and sisters or do i
have somebody out there that looks like
me that i'm like hey
we could be related like you know so it
depends on what you want
or if it's if it's for your own personal
life i need i i have a
a cross to bear and i want to get that
out whatever it is
you've already went through the trouble
you found him do something with that
information but just
know what that is is what i'm saying
know what it is
good luck these are good ones
what else we got wigs next one is
how do i outwork my peers in the
entertainment industry
what should i be doing all right the
reason why i got this question is
because
this this begs this screams of like that
you think that there's a comparison and
there isn't a comparison it's not
necessarily a race
entertainment business is more like golf
you have a leader board
but it's your own individual work that
you're putting in
it's you against the course it's you
against the entertainment business
and sometimes someone else might have
got a hole in one that you know was
lucky or somebody
or is just more skilled than you but it
doesn't mean that you can't beat the
course
it doesn't mean you can't win so it's
like
you don't compete with other people or
out work them
you just have to work do your work
you know because somebody might just
have an easier path so sometimes you you
know
are you working hard or are you working
smart you know are you working uh
sometimes you see someone else they go
they didn't even work hard maybe because
they didn't have to because they did a b
and c and your your path is gonna be
different
so what i my my advice for this is like
to get out of this
frame of thinking of that you're in say
competition with people
so you could steal from people like in
terms of like work ethic you go
oh i like what that person does like in
comedy i might see somebody
how they write they might have like a
notepad and they're always doing this
and then i'm like oh i like that
or i might hear somebody be like hey
when i get home i listen to my
recordings and i do a b
and c and i might go oh i really like
that or there might be someone else so
it's like
you're not necessarily outworking them
so much as you're like putting in your
own work
so put in your own work in your own way
and maximize your potential without
comparing it to other people
all right and that goes for everybody
good luck
they going in today huh that was a good
one what we got
okay next one is i'm indecisive
and anxious to the point of complete
inaction
how do i break the cycle see this is uh
i picked this one because
you know because of our sponsor
betterhelp betterhelp.com
um the thing is is um you know this is
one of these things where
there's a whole lot of things that could
be going on you know
when you're indecisive it's about like
not necessarily not being confident in
yourself it's like having you know
you know have some confidence in in in
what you're doing you know and that's
why you it
it kind of feeds itself it's like when
you're anxious but you're anxious
because you have no confidence and then
that's you have this indecisiveness
so it's like you know you have to plan
you need to plan things out
you know it's like you're not sometimes
we see the end result
and we think that it seems daunting like
you know let's say you know for me in
the comedy business it's like
i want to get on a television show or
even let's say something like
when i was first coming up it was like i
want to make it at the comedy store
i want to be a regular on the comedy
store stage so
if i don't know all the steps that it
takes to get there i might see that and
it'd be like
whoa it makes you anxious and you're
like you're indecisive because you don't
know
well how do i even do this and then it
just you just you just go
[ __ ] it and you're just overwhelmed and
you just take no action at all
well you break the cycle by breaking it
down work backwards
you know it's like i had to find out
that oh
you needed to get recommended by someone
uh you know you know you had to be ready
you had to keep working on your craft
you had to get like an audition and how
do you get that audition you have to
it has to be somebody that knows her it
had to be
knows mitzi at the time back in the day
i mean there was like so many steps that
once i started to see all the steps it
was like okay well let me now conquer
one step at a time
and once you start to conquer one step
at a time towards your
end goal work from working backwards
from that goal
then it doesn't become so daunting that
it just then
you're not necessarily indecisive
anymore because you're taking action
you're going you know what
i need to do this okay so i have to work
on my act first well let me then work on
my act
while i'm working on my act i'm building
relationships you got to build these
relationships and it's like you realize
oh this is going to take time i got to
cultivate this
like things aren't you know we spend so
much time looking at the end prize that
we forget about the journey and the
journey is important that's where all
the learning and the fun and all that
stuff comes in
that's where you build confidence the
journey build your confidence on that
journey
that will get rid of that indecisiveness
and then you're not gonna be anxious
anymore because you know
you're on the path and you know what you
need to do and then of course there's
going to be setbacks and things but
you're at least you're
you have it planned out now thought out
and you're going for it you're attacking
it
and then that's how you're going to
break that cycle so stop looking so far
ahead
if you're doing that and start work
backwards from your goal
and then now start taking those steps
even if they're baby steps
take those steps thank you
good luck i needed that one
for me i just like i have to force
myself to just get up and like do it
otherwise i just
yeah just procrastinate my life away
yeah you are procrastinating i'm
starting to see that him and i have the
same problem right i come back
wig's supposed to be here helping me and
his ad i'd be like we gonna do all this
stuff
we still gotta get this patreon going
and by the way speaking of i got the
patreons you know there
i don't have a lot of followers on
patreon so i'm cuz i don't do enough
content but i'm trying to
so every week i'm gonna try to do like a
live behind the scenes video on patreon
of us making the podcast
and when he's not here just me making
the podcast in and i'm also gonna try to
do a weekly live
of real world advice from acronyms man
on my instagram and that's at
eric griffin so so all the questions
that say don't make it onto the podcast
i'll do them live on instagram
so so you guys can still be a part of
that so
all right what's next next one is uh
how tf do i bounce back from getting
dumped off a long relationship
yeah this is a tough one man you know
when you when you're in a relationship
for a long time
you're so comfortable and you feel like
this is the person that i'm gonna be
with for the rest of my life even if
deep down you know that's not true but
you just become
comfortable and it becomes a relaxing
situation in terms of like
even even like a bad situation that
you're familiar with
feels better than trying to find
something new
and you're just like oh what the hell do
i do but obviously look it didn't work
out
it's time to work on you i say this
every time people talk about being
dumped and all this kind of stuff
this is the time now for you to work on
you be a better
version of yourself distract yourself
with working out distract yourself with
career goals distract yourself with
friends distract yourself with like
family and loved ones
start taking some time to make yourself
again
the best version of yourself so then
when you move forward you can look in
the mirror and be like you can look at
yourself in the mirror now and be like
well she dumped this guy
and then two years from now when you've
you you've completely altered yourself
you could be like oh i wouldn't even be
sh she can't even get with me now
you know that's you know you it's like
you have to just work on you
and in that process of working on you
you'll find something new about yourself
you know you'll be a better version of
yourself you'll be better for it but
don't harp on the past it's done it's
done
it's over it's done i know it was a long
time in your life
start thinking about all the things you
should have done while you were with
this person
think about all those like maybe could
you have done could you have made
different choices that would have
bettered yourself and you didn't do them
then
do them now do them now and you'll wake
up and then you'll be
this version of your stuff that you'd be
like damn
i'm ready i'm a catch make yourself a
catch
good luck boom boom
all right how do you stay motivated
after you've achieved
your goal in your career okay so this
the reason why i picked this one is like
what's your career like there's no such
thing what this person is saying
you know what i mean like your goals
change your goals change
and if you can achieve your goal so fast
in your career
it was then it was a you should have
picked an even bigger goal
but i get it though but this is a good
example of what i'm saying
so so in my comedy career i might say to
myself my goal was to be on a tv show
right
i did that i did that multiple times but
that's not enough
so it's like your goal evolves your
goals you know you stay motivated
because your goals evolved it's not it's
not just that it's like
so i go why i want to be on a tv show i
go i want to be the lead of a tv show
maybe i want to be on a network show i
want to make this amount of money i want
to be acknowledged for this maybe i want
to win a grammy and bring an emmy or
maybe i want to like your goals are ever
changing
they keep you know as you hit a goal
mark there's got to be more there's more
after that
but if you have some career that like if
you picked
if you picked like some goal where it's
just like okay i just wanted to do a
and then that's it i've achieved it in
my career so i'm done well what career
is that
you know it it it seems like
even if it's something grand like i
wanted to be a doctor well now it's like
okay
now that you are a doctor what's the
goals within that
it's like to save a thousand lives or do
this type of surgery or
you know i want to be on the cutting
edge of this and that like your goals
continue
to overlap and and so i'm saying it's
like don't feel
like you know i think you should you you
probably need
more grandiose goals and that's what
keep you motivated
like whatever your career is like you
know it's like within that career
find some other things find some
personal things find some things that
your career can take you to it's like
maybe you're a doctor and you're like
well i want to be doctors without
borders now it doesn't even have to be
like
it could be it could even be like a
lateral move it could be you know what i
mean where it's like okay i did i did
this
okay now i want to do this other thing
or even something that's even lesser but
you didn't get to accomplish it
but don't think that you know achieving
one thing
is like that's it for you it's like no
goals kind of fall upon themselves
and they like they they they cross they
they cross each other you know
it's like if you have like two circles
that like cross in the middle and
there's another area right there
like these things intersect man goals
and
achievements they intersect so keep
pushing yourself
keep pushing yourself that goes for
everybody good luck dude
boom all right next one is
should women have equal rights
to rejection and start asking out men
i mean you know we're still old school
you know we still
there's still a feeling that we have
that things should be done a certain way
you know that like men are supposed to
pay for dates and women are supposed to
like be the conquest
like we you know we're we're the chasers
we're the hunters and they're the hunted
that's old school
mentality i mean there's such a thing as
like well some women they want equity
and if
so the women listening if you know but
some people women old school teachers
like nah i like a man asking me out i
mean
if that's the dynamic that's in your
head that's fine too but i don't think
there's anything wrong with like
you know women women go ask men out too
if they can't
but this guy just feels like this feels
a little bit of like
you're tired of getting rejected and
you're like you want women to feel
rejection too
they feel rejection all the time even
when they're not even being rejected
they reject themselves you know if they
if they you know like we have their
people everyone experiences this in
their own way
so you got to stop worrying about
you know how bad you feel because
you've been rejected and projecting that
on to like well let's make them feel
that
too stop worrying about that if a strong
independent woman wants to ask you out i
don't think you're gonna be the type
that's gonna be like
i don't know if i like you unless you're
just not attracted to that person
and that's why she rejected you don't
forget that
you know so it's it's equal then you'll
probably have more empathy for when
how you are treating people
but just just be confident dude
and stop worrying about you know
what the how you feel slighted just this
maybe i'm reading too much
into it but this just feels like one of
those things because i've been this guy
i
know how he feels my sometimes my comedy
comes from this place and it i can make
it funny
but this also can be like considered
like you're like ah come on man don't be
don't be pathetic be confident and don't
worry about all this stuff that's going
on but
listen don't i mean but ultimately if
you're just making like a
like a societal statement i mean yeah i
mean i just
you know i'm for equal rights i'm for
equity if
if once i can experience it the other
side can experience it too like i always
say i think that you know
uh men should start calling the cops on
women who hit them
you know it's just one of those things
you just a lot of some people don't do
but i think you want to you want to make
things equal we need to start doing that
yeah
you know my my my wife my girlfriend
just punched me
and i think i need you to come get her
then
you know let's see what happens then
when it comes to like domestic violence
you know what i mean
but it's just not something that we do
we just kind of like deal with it right
but it's like so that's the kind of
thing where you go
is that equal but it's like you know i
don't know
you know it's either here nor there but
good luck dude
yeah i think girls are do this more now
i'd say yeah
exactly more than that especially in the
dms definitely exactly
yeah well you're you're life wigs i'm
sure
yeah wiggy's dms are just on fire
they're just on fire hey
baby what's next uh
what do you do when a girl you really
like puts you in the friend zone
well she can't you can't first of all i
don't believe in being put in the friend
zone
you know you you she opened the door and
you walked into the friend zone
she didn't put you there you went into
the friend zone willingly
because you didn't you weren't confident
in and clear about your intentions
you know what i mean like you can't let
nobody can put you in the friend zone
you just straight up like yo we i we're
i don't want to be your friend i'm
trying to date you i'm trying to get
with you
i'm not your friend okay your friend
picks you up from the airport you know
your friend
i'm not that's not me you know what i
mean like i'm trying to court you
i'm trying to date you i'm trying to get
with you make your intentions clear
man and if she's like well i'm not into
you that way then you know and you could
just move on
then at that point if you want to be
friends you're going to act differently
because that's the thing too sometimes i
don't like what chicks act like
you go well i just wanna be friends oh
you wanna be friends okay well friends
uh
pay they both pay when they go out okay
friends act differently with each other
so if you want to be pals we could be
pals but
you're not gonna get the courting
because i don't do that with my friends
i don't call my friend i don't call my
friends like yo
what's up dudes thinking about you you
know what i mean
this is courting stuff friends act
differently so don't act like our friend
yeah you can break out yeah you can
bring that guy's like i said like you
said if
if you can't then it's just you know you
just move on exactly
and she's not gonna be want that in
either she don't want to be friends with
you
right she don't want you acting like you
know what she said was
i want you to keep doing what you're
doing and i'm never gonna [ __ ] you
that's what that means in a lot of these
situations yeah
so you just go nah i'm trying to get
with you
i want that to be on the table and if i
try and fail
at least i took that shot but you're not
gonna deny me that shot
but if you're saying i have no chance
well then bye
[Music]
you just move on dude but anyway my
point about this is
you can't be put in the friend zone you
walk into the friend zone when they open
that door
no i walk over to the door and i go i
close that [ __ ] like
nah what's up i'm trying to get with you
so i did that to rachel she at first
wasn't sure she said to me
i have a whole bit about this i talk
about on stage and i did that she came
to my show
first time i met her and i did i have
bits about how i'm not gonna be your
friend
and i did that and i looked right at her
ass in the st in the audience while she
was with another dude
and i was like ah i'm not gonna be your
friend and i'm and i did that bit on
purpose because i was letting her know
so do what you got to do man but don't
don't have some confidence take a shot
you know let this girl know your
intentions like yo
i really like you don't you see that and
they see it
but they just waiting to see what are
you gonna do can i just put them in the
friend zone you know what i mean it's
like they made that
and maybe she don't want to be with
somebody she could just put in the
friend zone okay you want you in a crib
she picked you up like a baby and put
you in the crib
right maybe she wants a little pushback
yeah maybe she wants to see what
that's yeah they want to play a little
you know yeah little cat mouse
so you know use get some confidence bro
you know offer a cactus cooler
yeah i would okay so look at that i
don't know what that even meant
he's got a cactus queen oh okay i see
what you're saying is a
profile picture so uh yeah maybe just
get our characters cool
cactus cooler is good that's pretty
tasty all right next one is uh
x has found someone new how to handle
new guy
around my young daughter okay i don't
have kids but
i understand how this is a very delicate
situation
and i think this is one of these things
for these people out here who are in
these situations where
you know you have to have a conversation
with your ex
about this this is important to you you
don't want just anybody
around your daughter and i would hope
that her mother
feels the same way but at the same time
you have to have some sort of like
you got to have an agreement you got to
have some sort of like contract you guys
got to talk to each other
hate each other or not if you hate each
other or whatever you got to put all
that [ __ ] behind
because you need to focus on what is
best for your daughter
and you have to know you have to think
that you both are on that page
so that's the conversation you have to
have with your your your ex
you got to be about like yo
i know we're not going to work anymore
but let's make sure
what's up that our daughter has the
the best possible situation so it's
maybe it's a thing where you go
i really don't want you introducing my
my daughter to new men unless you're
serious with them or whatever
thing is make sure it's about the
well-being of your daughter and don't be
all in your feelings
you know because because it could just
be that you might miss your ex you might
be like she's
you know you're having trouble with that
you got to get past that [ __ ]
and start worrying about what is best
for your daughter
and then you and you could do some
self-care within that too of
realizing that you know what i got to
get out of my feelings
it didn't work with my ex and you know
but listen there's a
multitude of different situations that
could be happening in here you know
you know you know sometimes people make
bad choices and that kind of thing so
just
keep your daughter's folk you know
well-being in mind and
and see if you can have a a real adult
conversation with your ex about
what you want to do moving forward
because at the same time too she i bet
you
you she don't want no hood rats around
her daughter either you know what i mean
so you both have to like understand like
this is how we're going to do this
so have like an agreement of like this
is how we're going to do this if we're
both going to start dating
let's do it this way moving forward and
hopefully you can you know come to an
understanding and if not
man i know how hard that is and and good
luck
what else we got we got any more oh we
do wow we got some
a lot of them today guys okay i think
this is the last one
how do you mend a broken relationship
with a family member
is it possible it is possible um
i have broken relationships with with
family members that i and i'm stubbornly
i stubbornly have not tried to do
anything because i feel i'm bitter
you know you get mad you know you think
back to like
why are we in this situation like you
know we could this could have worked out
it can work out you know it's
i've said this before and it applies in
all sorts of relationship situations but
here's the thing
do you want to be right or do you want
to have
a better relationship with your family
that's what you have to ask yourself
so that just means if you're in a
situation where you feel like you've
been wronged
and i need an apology well you're that
that's not the way to approach it
you know again do you want to be right
or do you want a
happy relationship with your family
decide
because that's going to be some give and
take it's going to be some compromise
there's going to be some concessions
that are going to have to be made
and you reach out with that energy
and see where it goes from there you
know but our ego gets in the way
and it becomes hard i'm i know i'm
speaking from
my own experience it's hard sometimes
it's hard to like let go it's hard to be
like nah you wrong and
i need you to admit that you're wrong
when you don't need that anymore
that's when that relationship can
possibly thrive again
but you got to start at a place that
you're willing
to negotiate your feelings you're
willing to
let things go for the betterment of
moving
forward i know how hard that is it's
easy to say
i know how hard it is but it can be done
just try to get that mentality
in your head we all should try that and
uh like i say good luck buddy
big facts there's a new t-shirt coming
soon
big facts uh well you know we did it
that this has been like
we almost had an hour look at that see
when wigs is here we get [ __ ] done
um but listen guys procrastination who
[Laughter]
we still should be doing more come on
dude yeah look i pick a guy that's just
like me that we're just sitting here
like
we're gonna do this video bro i got a
lot of stuff planned yo okay
we'll see we're gonna hold him to that
phone
music video yeah we're gonna do yeah he
wants to do a music he wants to direct a
music video
you know what i mean so we'll see guys
what what's going to happen so
and send us some emails too if you like
uh you know if you want to
send some instagram messages and stuff
and keep subscribing and sharing and
liking and i appreciate you guys uh
being here i know there's gonna be a lot
of hot comments about everything i was
talking about in this episode especially
the britney stuff but free brittany
free brittany and um thanks for watching
big shout out to everybody remember a
better help and helix sleep thank you
for being sponsors and
and thanks for for wigs shout out to
being here
um julian clark what's up thanks for
watching
and uh you know thanks for being here
with griffin
and guys see you next week
[Music]
you